I think that it really kind of isn't a
choice I think if if you are a committed
member of society and you understand the
influence that you can have and you feel
responsible to you know fight and
justices or to to really try to fight
for equality then you don't really have
a choice but to engage and I guess I
feel that I was so lucky to be born in
this position where you know I have food
to eat I have clean water to drink I
have a community of people that support
me and so why not use that amazing base
to try to make more people in that
position as well as I'd like to talk
about that a little bit
we've had other conversations with
people who did not come to embracing the
particular position that they're in
where they could be a wealth holder
where they have a platform in media we
are they didn't have any of the tools
that you have that you you're
comfortable and embracing what was it in
your background do you think that
allowed you to take on these challenges
so young well it was tricky I mean it
wasn't it was kind of a conscious choice
because you know not to kind of like
dwell on this too much but it's a little
weird when you realize at an early age
that you have a lot of wealth and that
people are associating you with that and
so and I see a lot of peer group people
in my peer group struggle with that and
they don't kind of it's it's almost like
the secret that they want to hide and I
just think that's unproductive I
understand it but it's not productive
and so why not kind of embrace that and
say okay well what what can I do with
this situation instead of running away
from it but I think that that's that's
actually it's it's not an easy choice
necessarily because you always want to
be identifying with I don't know
opportunities that you don't have as
opposed to taking advantage of the ones
that you do and I think also for young
people sometimes to say I'm a full-time
philanthropist so I'm a philanthropist
makes you almost you don't want to be
considered a socialite right and so
that's that's also I think a little bit
tricky and so if you don't want to be
considered a socialite but don't do
social lytic philanthropy like do it the
way you want to do it